you
hi everyone it's Jerry about one month
before I created this chest network
youtube channel magnus carlsen was
competing against his dad henrik Carlsen
at the Arctic chest challenge held in
tromsø Norway this game was played on
April 8th 2007
both Magnus and Henrik accumulated three
and a half tournament points out of
their first five rounds and sure enough
come round six they were paired up they
were sitting across the board from one
another
Magnus playing with the white pieces
sixteen years old at the time with a
rating of about 2700 his father playing
with the black pieces of course just shy
of a 2100 rating 2089
to be exact so let's dive in and see the
type of beating Magnus was prepared to
give Papa Bear over the board
rumor has it that before the game
started Henrik said to his son Magnus if
you beat me you're grounded
that's totally made-up but I think it's
kind of funny if something like that
would have happened funny for everybody
except for Magnus right d4 on board papa
bear replying with Knight to f6 c4 e6
we're entering a queen's gambit declined
exchange variation
and with Bishop to g5 this is noted as
the positional one
pending the night to the Queen that is
broken III c6 and Queen to c2 not
deploying the kingside binder pieces
just yet Queen c2 is designed to prevent
Bishop to f5
if Bishop f5 was played one move sooner
there can be some problems but they
capture on f6 and then Queen to b3
there's an issue with both d5 and b7
so okay c6 Queen c2 on board a little
jab is thrown at the bishop and a flight
square is produced white ducks castles
Bishop to d3 there's a little battle
going on over the e4 square multiple
pieces
competing for that square Knight and
pawn on blacks End and whites pieces are
pointing there as well
rook to e8 observing efore indirectly
night g2e to
Knight to f3 there's Knight to e2 by
playing to e2 white keeps open the
option for a central expansion f3 and e4
to be more specific
black plugs up that e4 hole
are exchanged
black is recapturing at the queen and
developing and now we have Bishop takes
Knight on takes of course and a big
change just occurred from that minor
piece imbalance is now present as well
as a slight shift in the structure this
pond now could potentially move
following up we have Knight to g3 adding
some fire more fire to e4 there's only
one way to adequately defend efore f5 is
it
castles
Knight to a6 is looking to now sink into
the d3 square if white is not careful so
that's ruled out
Knight to c7 and now f3 breaking down
chipping away at this structure this
lead pawn this head pawn on e4
he takes F
rook takes and white is now exerting
pressure on f5 where seventeen moves in
and this is where black slips up
black goes for f4 here
pitching upon in order to activate the
bishop
better is for black to simply lend some
more support to the f5 point rook to
Effie it's not a fun move to do to pull
a rook off of this half open file and go
to one where you know you're just
babysitting upon but it's necessary to
defend a5 and rook to f8 is one of the
better ways better in my opinion than g6
is kind of want to keep this structure
around to be your king shelter the g7 h6
structure
Brook 2f8 was not played though f4
is upon and yeah it's really just a
difficult road ahead after this advance
he takes F
to g4
that's just sidestep simple enough
rook to d8 and now there's a big issue
with this last move I wonder if you can
spot it there's a really good move that
Carlson which Carlson there's a really
good move that Magnus plays here on move
20 if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video what move would you play here as
white
okay the move played
five why is this so powerful well where
is this Bishop going this advance is now
preventing the Bishop from retreating
along this diagonal he is now very
limited no safe squares besides the one
he sits on and that is soon to be taken
away so he's in some serious hot water
and now black has to try to stir up some
trouble but it's just short-lived any
any attempt to muddy the waters here
Henrick captures on d4
Magnus replying with Queen to have to
there's no rush was playing h3 queen f2
is throwing a punch at the rook and you
know preventing Queen to e3 width check
that goes in for a queen exchange h3 is
there
you know not too many good squares for
that Bishop black is in some really big
trouble
rook to d2 is tried queens are exchanged
and now we have a nice move there's
multiple of good moves here for white
rook to f2 was played offering a rook
exchange on rook takes rook if this is
played
white would recapture and now there's
two issues for black to cope with so
what is attempted here is rook takes
Knight one other quick variation if
let's say rook to d3 there can simply
follow Knight to f1 parrying black's
threat and you know we have another case
where now - there are two issues for
team black two pieces under are under
fire
so what was played in the game is rook
takes Knight allowing rook takes rook
and Bishop takes pawn so why does just
taking a moment here white is up the
exchange as a rook versus a bishop in
this case at the Knights offset a pair
of rooks offset and so what's remaining
really is a rook versus Bishop type
position and well black also has a pawn
for it five pawns versus whites four but
this is not going to be enough the rook
is just far superior than the bishop in
this endgame
so Magnus just activates the rook that
was in the corner
both are really good here on these
central files the Dae files
King to have seven the bishop is now
thrown into a pin black gets out of it
but now we have a rook entering on the
sixth rank
any even exchanges are favoring white
and eventually this is what happens
Richie one
King to f7 defending the bishop in
getting out of this pin but now here
comes the night throwing a punch at the
rook eyeing up the c5 square that
happens Knights e5 is hitting everything
now so not too much to do b6 is played
but this is a threat light can now
ignore picking up a pawn on c6 and
throwing a punch at the knight pawn
takes Knight rook takes Knight with's
check King to g8 or to c6 and now Henrik
goes in for a
small combination that Nets upon but and
just to move or to later
Magnus is getting that pond back so
let's see this little combination rook
takes g2 King takes G to with now the
follow-up Bishop to d5 with the fork
after king g3 and Bishop takes rock
Oliver rook c1 is the last move this
game saw at this point team black Henrik
Magnus's dad threw in the towel at this
stage the sea Pond is a gonner and as
mentioned earlier the rook is just far
too superior to the bishop in this end
game if this game was to continue king
f7 rook takes pawn and in fact we're
already seeing that once the bishop
moves we're gonna have rook to c7 and
there goes another pawn and we got two
runners here to pass pawns that are soon
to score a touchdown but that's played
out in this game rook to c1 was the last
one and Magnus's father threw in the
towel at this stage so an interesting
game of son vs father and I don't know
how I would feel if I was paired up
against my father at a tournament I
don't know how would you feel maybe you
can share your thoughts in the comment
section below
yeah how would you feel if you were
paired up against a family member maybe
this is something that's happened with
you at a chess tournament and also
another thing another question I think
it'd be pretty cool to see in the
comments how did you get introduced to
the game I think many players can relate
to being introduced to this to this game
by their father I know that that was the
case for me so I learned when I was 8
and yeah feel free to share maybe what
age you learned the game and who
introduced you to the great game of
chess in the comments section below
feel free to leave that feedback so
anyhow I hope you enjoyed this game as
usual appreciate any feedback and hope
you're having a great time that's all
for now take care bye
you